i touched on this a little bit in the
video on how variation can be introduced
into a population but i think it's
fairly common knowledge that all of us
where i talk about us i'm talking about
human beings and frankly most eukaryotic
organisms were the product of sexual
reproduction so if this is
the the first cell that could that had
the potential to become
sal
we know that this first cell let me say
this is the nucleus of that first cell
so i could draw the whole cell and all
of that let's just focus on the nucleus
that it has 23 chromosomes or let me put
this it has 46 chromosomes 23 from my
father and 23 from my mother so it's 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 21 22 23 from my father and then
let's say that last one actually helps
to determine my gender or it fully
determines my gender that's my y
chromosome and let's say i had 23
homologous chromosomes or
one chromosome that kind of was the
homolog for each of these but i have 23
of them from my mother so
one two three four five i'll just
you get the idea yeah i could just draw
a bunch of them and then i have the x
chromosome that
that was is essentially the the gender
one of the gender determining chromosome
from my mother and we learned before
that each of these pairs are our
homologous chromosomes that they
essentially code for the same
gene one from my father and one from my
mother now that first cell that had the
potential to become me it was the
product of fertilization of
an egg from my mother
so an egg from my mother let me so the
egg from my mother the nucleus well i'll
just draw the whole egg like that
and it had and let me just do the i'll
just draw focus on the dna from now so
my mother's dna it had 23 chromosomes so
it didn't have pairs and this is key so
it's one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21 22 and then 23 was the
let's say that's the x chromosome
and so it's a combination of this from
my mother so this is from my mother
and a sperm from my father
so let me do that here and i'll draw the
sperm much larger than it is normally
relatively egg this is kind of the
nucleus of the egg but let's say that
this is a sperm
and it has a tail that helps it swim
and it has it has 26 chromosomes sorry
23 chromosomes so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 and
then it has that y chromosome and let me
do that y chromosome in a separate color
and this is a side this unification this
fertilization that occurred from this
sperm cell to this egg cell so it
essentially penetrates into this egg
cell and it creates this zygote which is
a fertilized which is a fertilized egg
cell from my mother and it this contains
all dna from both my father and my
mother so this very first cell that was
created from this fertilized egg this is
called a
zygote
and it's a product of fertilization
between two gametes
gametes
so that's a gamete
and this is a gamete
so you can view these uh both a sperm
cell or a egg cell they're both examples
of gametes now the whole reason why i'm
doing this is i want to introduce you
well and i already introduced this
notion to you when we talked about
variation of population is that look
this has my full
my full chromosome complement it has 23
23 pairs
and each pair is a pair of homologous
chromosomes they essentially code for
the same things one from my mother one
from my father
and that is 46 chromosome 46 individual
chromosomes
46 chromosomes 23 for my mother 23 from
my father
these gametes
they each have only 23 chromosomes 23
chromosomes
or half the number
half the number of a full complement 23
chromosomes now everything that i'm
talking about here the number 46 or 23
pairs or 23 individual chromosomes this
is unique to human beings if i talked
about other species they might have
10 chromosomes or they might have five
chromosomes but one thing that is
universal for all sexually reproducing
organisms is that gametes have half the
number of chromosomes as the zygote or
as or as you can kind of view it as the
the organism itself the way you know we
conventionally think about it so when
people talk about half the number of
chromosomes they say it has a haploid
number
and that literally just means half the
number of chromosomes it's very easy to
know
to to memorize because haploid starts
with the same two letters as half
haploid
haploid number
for humans
is 23 chromosomes
and so you say oh if you say this is a
haploid number what do you call it when
you have the full complement of
chromosomes well that's called the
diploid number
diploid
diploid number and i remember that
because die often is a prefix associated
with
having a two of something and so you
have twice the number of chromosomes so
this haploid this is
diploid number and this is for humans
right for a for an organism that where
the diploid number is n and you'll
sometimes see this notation sometimes i
want to make sure you're comfortable
with it
there's some organism or actually any
organism if the diploid number is 2n
then the haploid number
is going to be half of that or just n
now in the case of humans the diploid
number is 46 so n is equal to 23. so a
fertilized egg or even a just a regular
somatic cell or body cell will have a
diploid number of chromosomes while a a
sex cell and i'll be a little bit clear
about that in a second we'll have a
haploid number of chromosomes so gametes
which are either a sperm or an egg those
are both examples of gametes they either
they have half the number they merge and
then you get a zygote which is that very
first cell that has the potential that
had the potential to turn into me that
has a diploid number of chromosomes i
actually want to do a little bit of a
side here because it's fascinating you
know we talk about natural selection and
we even wonder today you know to what
degree is it occurring because our
society it kind of it's not as as tough
of an environment as as the natural
world would be where we're being stalked
by predators and we have to live out in
the wild and find food and all of that
but even this process of fertilization
is an incr it is an incredibly
competitive process because
this this this
sperm that happened to be the one that
kind of won the race to uh from my
father to fertilize my mother's egg it
was actually the first of roughly 200
million other sperms
there were 200 million roughly i mean
couldn't two to 300 million other sperms
in that race
so we're all all already the product
from the moment we're born we're already
the product of an intense competition
amongst these male i guess we could call
male gametes or amongst these sperm
cells you know some of them might have
had weird mutations that you know they
they didn't know which direction to swim
they happened to go the wrong direction
maybe some of them had weird tails that
didn't allow them to swim as fast so
you're already on some level selecting
for fitness within this environment so
if you had some weird mutations from the
get-go and some of these sperm cells it
would have been less likely especially
if they affected their ability to kind
of swim it would have been less likely
that they would have been the ones to
win this race so already you are the
product of a race of
million organisms if you consider each
of these sperm cells an organism and you
are the product of that winning
combination so you know sometimes we
feel lost on this planet we're one of
six billion people and all that we're
just a nut but we already are the are
are the product of a pretty pretty
intense accomplishment but now with this
you know kind of some of this um
vocabulary
thrown out of the way let's talk a
little bit about zygotes and how do
zygotes turn into people and then how do
those people
essentially produce gametes which then
can fertilize other people's gametes
to form more zygotes
so the general idea so that very first
cell that was essentially my mom's egg
fertilized by a sperm cell from my
father that was a zygote
and as soon as it's successfully
fertilized it has 2n or it has the
diploid number of chromosomes in the
case of humans which i believe i am one
of them i have 46 chromosomes
and then this cell right here begins to
split and divide over and over and over
again we'll do a whole series of videos
on the actual mechanics of that but it
splits by a mechanism called mitosis
mitosis and mitosis literally is just a
cell splitting to form copies of itself
so it just starts splitting into
two more cells that are two and actually
let me do it this way just because the
actual way it works is right when a cell
is split the the
cells that it splits into aren't that
much larger than the original one but
now each of these have two n chromosomes
or 46 in the case of humans and you keep
keep splitting and it happens over and
over and over again so eventually so you
know then these these keep let me just
do it this way then this keeps splitting
and then you have
and i'll go into the there are words for
some of these initial collections of
cells but i won't go into that right now
2n all of these are original copies from
a genetic point of view of that original
cell and then eventually
they start to really you know i start to
have tons of them
there's a there's just a gazillion of
them that starts to
that you know just they're all
duplicates of this cell and they all
contain the 2n number of chromosomes the
diploid number of chromosomes they all
contain that all of my genetic material
but based on how they relate to each
other and what they see around them they
start differentiating
so maybe and so all of these have two n
numbers so they're all diploid and the
mitosis is this is the process the whole
time is these divide uh one cell into
two cells and those two cells into four
cells and keep going and then these
begin to differentiate maybe these cells
eventually differentiate into things
that will turn to my brain
these cells right here to differentiate
into things that will turn into my heart
these cells here differentiate into
things that will turn into my
lungs and so forth and so on and
eventually
you get a in the case and you get a
human being but it doesn't have to be a
human being it could be whatever species
we happen to be talking about so let me
draw the human being
so i'll draw just
let me see my best shot at an outline of
a human being
so eventually and you know now we're
talking about gazillions of cells
you have your human being
and i'll just draw
a very simple
diagram outline of a human being
let's see
when i was in high school i was a class
artist so i don't want to make this
representative of my true artistic
ability i'm doing this here just to
kind of
give you an idea
but anyway eventually you keep dividing
these cells and you end up with a human
being this human being you know you sell
you wouldn't even notice the cells on
this scale now
most of these cells of this human being
if this is me or you these are all the
products of mitosis
that started off with that zygote and it
just kept dividing and dividing and
dividing into into mitosis a bit
differentiated into you know i said some
of them will turn into brain cells some
of them will turn into heart cells and
we that the whole process of
differentiation is actually fascinating
and we'll talk a lot more about that
when we talk about stem cells
but uh embryonic stem cells and maybe
we'll even talk about the debate a bit
but
the question is well how do i then
produce those gametes how do i produce
those things that eventually if i'm
going to reproduce uh turn into uh uh
these kind of haploid number of cells
and that's what happens in your in your
sexual organs so in a male
you have some germ cells so some of
these
cells turn into germ cells
and the germ cells exist part of your
your reproductive organs so let's say
those are germ cells in a male they
would be part of the gonads
so they would be there and in a female
they would be involved in the ovaries
and these germ cells they're the product
of mitosis so let me draw a germ cell
so a germ cell
is the product of mitosis so it still
has
2n
number of chromosomes so it still is a
diploid
it is still is a diploid cell or has a
diploid number but what's special about
a germ cell is it has a potential one it
could either do mitosis
it could either continue to do mitosis
and produce more germ cells that are
identical to it so it could produce two
germ cells that are identical to it
or
it can undergo meiosis
meiosis
meiosis and meiosis is essentially what
a germ cell undergoes to produce gametes
and so if this germ cell undergoes
meiosis and i'll do a whole video on the
mechanics of it it'll actually produce a
set of two cells that'll actually
produce
four cells
that each have
half the number
of of chromosomes in them so these cells
are haploid
haploid in the case of a male these
would be sperm cells
this would be sperm
in the case of a female in the ov these
would be ova
sperm or
ova and these are the gametes so it's an
interesting thing to talk about because
in the last several videos i talked a
lot about mutations and what does that
do to a species but think about what
happens if i have a mutation in some
cell here some somatic cell some body
cell somatic cell
somatic cell
will that mutation or can that mutation
in any way affect what's going to happen
to my kids will that mutation be carried
on to my kids well no because in no way
will what goes on in this cell affect
what i actually pass on eventually in in
the sperm cells it'll just be a random
mutation it could affect my ability to
reproduce for example it could be um you
know god forbid it could be some type of
uh of cancer or something that
especially if you if you contracted at a
young age it it it might be some type of
terminal form so that might affect your
ability to reproduce but it will not
affect what you pass the actual dna that
you pass on to your to your offspring so
this could if you have some really bad
mutation here it could affect how you
live or it could affect it it could turn
cancers and start reproducing but it
will not affect what you pass on to your
to your children the things that the the
traits that will be passed on or the
changes that will be passed on are those
that occur in the germ cells so if you
have mutations in your germ cells or
during the process of meiosis you have
essentially recombination of dna because
of crossovers and we saw that in the
variation video then that will introduce
new forms or new variants inside that
could be passed on to your children i
really want to make that point clear
because we talk about mutations but
there's different types of mutations
there's some mutations that won't be
passed on to your children
and those are the ones that occur in
your somatic cells maybe some of them do
nothing so that it really doesn't affect
your overall function but then the
mutations that either occur in your germ
cells or occur
or
or the the recombination or the
variation that is introduced during
meiosis that will be passed on to your
children but even there i want to be
careful because remember this is a
severe competition so out of all of the
let's say there's 280 million sperm
cells that at one time are being
competitive for an egg
it's possible that some of them have
mutations
some of them have mutations in order for
that one of those mutations let me do
the mutations in different colors that's
a purple mutation that's a
blue mutation but in order for that
mutation to truly be passed on to my
offspring the one the the sperm
containing the mutation is the one that
has to win the race so already you have
a selection going on at kind of this uh
at kind of the sexual reproduction level
where you're selecting for things that
are at least good enough i mean the the
to some degree the sperm has to be good
enough to win this incredibly incredibly
competitive race so that mutation
somehow made the sperm deformed or
didn't allow it to swim or made it
behave in some weird way it's very
unlikely that that mutation would go on
to be the one or that that cell would go
on to be the one that would successfully
fertilize an egg so anyway i wanted to
introduce you to these ideas the main
idea is really some of the vocabulary
haploid diploids it's very confusing
when you first learn it but it literally
just means half the the normal
contingency of the normal
group of chromosomes and in the case of
humans that would be 23 and the the
cells that are that have a haploid
number of chromosomes are our gametes
which are sperm cells for men and ova or
egg cells for women but everything else
in our body all of our somatic cells are
diploid which means they have the full
complement of chromosome they all have a
copy of our dna and that's why dna
testing is so interesting because you
can get any cell from someone anywhere
and you have their full complement of
dna you have all of the information that
describes them genetically anyway see in
the next video